the war causes me grief we we had a
bloody month in April 51 Americans
killed every one of those Americans who
died had wives mothers fathers neighbors
brothers sisters its tragedy every all
51 times a tragedy we have lost going on
40 100 Americans tens of thousands
wounded a third of them grievously
wounded missing eyes more than 3000
double amputees paralysis and of course
one out of every five has head trauma so
badly that they need care for this next
generation I can't imagine the American
people endorsing this war is causing us
$5,000 a second a second 24 hours a day
seven days a week what more you can say
the American people can't endorse this
war no I think the opposite is going to
continue the problem we've had and not
being more successful in office are your
opposition to the war has been we have a
majority but it is ever so slim before
the nine new democratic senators were
sworn in in January Tim Johnson from
South Dakota Democrat had a very bad
bleed on the brain was unconscious near
death for five weeks he was out of work
for ten months so my majority dropped to
52-49 and with joe lieberman who votes
with us on virtually everything else
against us every step of the way on our
trying to change the course of war in
Iraq I had no majority was 49 to 50 but
in spite of that we did some good things
we up-armored the vehicles in spite of
the presents opposition we got more body
armor for the troops we took care of the
scandal at Walter Reed we've done many
good things for the veterans the
Republicans refused to help us
so we're going to continue working but
the good news as we speak we have we are
competitive in 11 Senate races around
the country 11 Senate races I don't know
how many will pick up but right now our
margins one wouldn't it be wonderful if
my margin was five or six
you